so coloniality so coloniality I want you
to think of coloniality is essentially
the structures which enabled collodion
colonialism so it's both the social
orders and it's the forms of knowledge
that are produced under colonialism and
which continue to exist even after
independence is achieved and so the big
question for post-colonial societies is
what should our newly found identity be
you can't return to who you were before
colonialism so you have to think about a
new identity which both incorporates the
trauma of colonialism but also seeks to
resurrect many of the ideals and values
that were essentially considered to be
worthless by those that were in
governance and so it's about learning to
over overturn what the the African
thinker misses our describes of millions
of men who've been skilfully injected
with fear inferiority complexes
trepidation civility despair and a
basements so just those that's that's
all that you have to get over as an
entire society in order to come to think
of yourself in autonomous terms and as I
said there could be no return to what
was before so this has led to very
painful conversations in post-colonial
societies across the world about what
exactly that new identity should be and
what I find interesting in those
conversations is that actually that
there's a recognition of the harms that
happened under colonialism but during
those those conversations there's also a
recognition of what not wanting to
repeat some of the patterns of thinking
that happened then and so to produce
perhaps a more socially conscious form
of renewal which learns from the
mistakes of the past now what was very
interesting to me being half French
myself was the extent to which the
conversations about post-colonial
identity aren't really happening in what
were the centres of empire so the
centres of empire are the places where
the systems of thought which allowed the
subjugation which permitted which
facilitated the subjugation of entire
parts of the world which essentially
created moral social hierarchies of
human beings have not been properly
challenged in the very hearts of empire
where they were being developed and so
my big question is whether or not we
shouldn't maybe be concerned about the
extent to which those systems have
thought continue to permeate the way we
think about the world and continue to
influence structures within our own
society and perhaps we in not dealing
with that legacy are missing out also on
fully acknowledging the wealth of ideas
and cultural impact that we can get from
everybody who is now British today so so
as I said I don't feel there's been a
proper questioning of the center and I
think for me it's a little bit the
analogy I would make is one of a very
vicious crime having occurred the
victims are left reeling from that act
they're struggling to find a new normal
they're struggling to develop an
identity in the wake of that trauma and
the perpetrator sort of doesn't see a
reason to address the reasons that led
them to undertake that action in the
first place so my suggestion is that
there needs to be a sort of proper moral
inventory within colonial centres to
assess how it is that as cultures we not
only fostered ideas which permitted the
subjugation of others but develops you
know entire cultural corpuses around
this from literature to the arts to
philosophy our societies in many ways
were built out of a sense of supremacy
over others and if we don't dismantle
that we will continue to feed that to
people in various ways now given that
culture was both a means and an end of
colonial conquest I think there's a
responsibility therefore for us to
assess how contemporary culture both
perpetuates and the parts of course from
colonial assumptions now my premise is
that we haven't really dealt with this
issue properly and my reasons for
thinking this are manifold
I'll start out with things like you know
Jeremy Paxman series a few years ago
called Empire which essentially sought
to highlight all of the the great things
that the British Empire had done in the
world and that's not be so hard on
ourselves or more recently a professor
at my former University professor Nigel
bigger who called from the British to
moderate our post imperial guilt just as
he begins to head up a new five-year
project entitled ethics and Empire which
essentially seeks to argue for the moral
worth of Empire and they're not alone
that's kind of the issue they're not
alone in that
a recent you got poll shows that almost
60% of Britons think the British Empire
is something to be proud of rather than
ashamed of almost 50 percent think that
the colonized countries are better off
being colonized and a third of British
people said they would like it if
Britain still had an empire don't worry
about asking the people under the Empire
that that bit doesn't that's irrelevant
to the conversation but but in many ways
this nostalgia British nostalgia for
Empire should have really come as a
surprise in the wake of the arguments
I've been building by and large the
memory of Empire has been preserved
through the lens of the victors it's a
rose tempted attempt in many ways to
find moral goods in an enterprise which
we need to be honest about never had at
its core the well-being of the colonized
and that needs that's a really important
fact to bear in mind because you know
people like to bring in the railways and
you know there was a few hospitals set
up sure that was never the objective we
were not there to assist anyone now
rarely have we heard from the viewpoint
of the colonizers themselves and that
that to me is one of the big emissions
here that I don't think we hear enough
from those who were the victims of
Empire and more than this I feel that
the cultural edifice is the literature
the films the philosophy there are all
of the things which buttress and fueled
Empire haven't really been dismantled so
back to my personal story and my
interest in this I took up a position
after my PhD at so us for those of you
who don't know it it's the School of
Oriental and African Studies in London
which was actually founded to further
Imperial interests initially but now
prides itself on being the the bad kids
of academia and I let you decide that
for yourself
so my University is basically a growing
one of a growing number which is trying
to call for a decolonization of
Education what does that mean I hear you
say well decolonizing education is a
project that has many facets to it and
in many ways it started with insight it
started in South Africa the movement
with a call to tear down the statue of
Cecil Rhodes who's considered the
architect of apartheid and whose statue
was at the center of the campus at the
University of Cape Town now in parallel
to that campaign a number of students at
the University of Oxford also started to
call for the statue to be cooled down
there's a big statue of roads also
Oriole choral College in Oxford's in the
wake of this other movements that other
universities started to do the same
thing and begin their own decolonized
campaigns at Queen Mary University in
London a plaque to the Belgium King
Leopold who was responsible for the
massacre of millions of people from the
Congo was removed at Oxford there was a
change in the history degree to include
non British and non-european
examinations within the history degree
and UCL itself has run a course called a
campaign rather called why is my
curriculum white criticizing the
dominance of white Eurocentric writers
and thinkers in degree courses because
you know there were people outside of
the white Western world who did theorize
and think about the world in ways which
are actually quite valuable to arson may
actually help us to think about issues
not only in different ways but in ways
which might help address some of the
problems we face today at my own
University
students out the decolonize are mine
campaign and there's currently a
conversation with the authorities on
campus about how to decolonize the
campus but it's not just happening here
in America Harvard recently announced
the unveiling of a plaque dedicated to
the memory of four slaves who lived and
worked at the home of the university's
former presidents drew Faust declared
that the institution was I quote
directly complicit in America's system
of racial bondage and that despite some
efforts the history of slavery at
Harvard had Riley rarely been
acknowledged or invoked in Australia New
South Wales University recently set new
guidelines stating that Australia's
history should be described as an
invasion and occupation rather than a
softer sounding settlement in brief the
decolonizing movement is already in
motion it's beginning to happen but it's
not just happening here it's happening
internationally because there's a
growing recognition that there are
currently two histories being told and
until we start to merge them none of us
are really getting the full picture I
want to say thank you so much for
listening it's the beginning of a
conversation and I hope it will continue
thank you